here's a story from goldcast it says
homeless man
hands out resumes on the street and gets
hundreds of job offers okay
so here's the story you're talking about
this baby here we go so big shout out to
david casares he moved out to california
to pursue his dream as a tech
entrepreneur
soon to only find out that his dream
was crushed his dream was to create an
app called mesa which helps mom and pop
food businesses grow very admirable but
the app had a tough time getting started
he started missing his car payments he
had student debt that was piling up he
couldn't pay that and sooner rather than
later he ended up living
on the streets so at his lowest point
being homeless he wore a dress shirt and
tie he got out there and he started
engaging with oncoming drivers but
here's the deal and here's the moral of
the story he was not looking for a
handout
instead
he was handing out resumes
no david he was not looking for a hand
job talk about hand job
looking for a job i'll take any job i
can get a job all right i'm in
all right that's attainment david you're
fired thank you i'm sorry it's just so
easy it's so easy i wasn't looking for a
handout
look at bernie hj
respect
it's actually hilarious you gotta you
gotta you gotta
take your hat off to david on that one i
said he was handing out resumes
all right so he held up a sign i don't
know if we got this thing that we there
there he is right there our friend david
casarez with a suit and tie there he
goes he held up a sign that read
for success
take a resume you never know what will
happen take a resume so one lady
impressed she took notice and asked him
for his permission to post it on social
media right he said yes and by the end
of the night it hit almost a ha 10 000
shares leading to interviews and job
offers from all over so here's the
bottom line casara says look i came out
to california to be a tech entrepreneur
to build an app called mesa you know i
want to help people failed miserably
it's all good
but
rather than you know
looking for a handout yeah yeah or an h
he says his mindset is what made all the
difference he says
i have always kept a can do attitude
that's how i've always lived my life so
shout out to david here's the lesson
here
right here's the lesson here life's
going to knock you down you know they
say you get knocked down 11 times you
get back up 12 right it's not how many
times you get knocked down it's how many
times you get back up so shout out to
you
you know obviously if i were
homeless
i'd i'd be
scared
i'd have fear
i wouldn't know my next moves you know
pbd shout out to him know your next five
moves when you're homeless you're just
looking for your next one move right
well they say that fear can either mean
face everything and run
face everything and run or
you can face everything and rise so
shout out to david casarez for doing the
option too when it comes to fear facing
everything arise respect to you
hopefully you're no longer homeless
hopefully you're not giving out hj's
hopefully your your resume worked out
well for you got a job respect to you
but i do like that story
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken
[Music]